all right TT yes TZ where you grew up
where are you from originally
what well actually I stayed in Hollywood
so I'm kind of half bougie half ghetto
okay and tell me about your family
you're up with both of your parents no I
grew up with my grandmother and my mom
my mom was in another house my dad
prison majority my whole life I lost my
granny at 27 which was a about a year
ago so I'm kind of adjusting to not
having my granny cuz she always saved me
from everything she was really muscle
bear oh yeah it's nice to have somebody
like that you're like yes because no
matter what I did she had my back 100%
my mom on the other hand I think my
mom's kind of jealous of me because she
tried to sleep with one of my baby
daddies and I didn't understand why but
my mom has a drinking problem so that
could be a reason of why but I never
really understood my mom like certain
things she do cuz I think she tries to
hurt me on purpose
what age were you when you left your
mom's house 25 Oh whole do you know we
just turned 28 on the 16th of December
happy birthday thank you thank you do
you have kids of your own
yes I have five kids I have no key which
is 11 I have nine I which is eight I
have
melly-mel which is my dad I call him
King which is five and Minaya which is
three and my fat day which is Amir which
he's three months gonna be for me oh
yeah baby
yes so what are you doing for money now
occasionally I'll catch dates I try not
to that's often as some women would
because I I'm that's really not my
lifestyle like I graduated medical
school medical assistant cardiac
technician I was working at a doctor's
office but some kind of way I started
thinking about my first two kids getting
took from me behind marijuana and I
still haven't figured out it so you lost
your first tooth oh yes I still don't
know how to cope with that because my
two kids are actually with a lesbian
white couples that are married
and I'm not okay with that but I guess
it was for a reason do you ever see your
first two kids they won't let me they
won't let me have no type of contact
with then they were taken away why
because of marijuana I tested positive
for marijuana when I had my daughter and
she didn't test positive but I did
so they took them for me August 15th
2012
tell me about making money dating guys
what kind of guys do you pick up
sometimes I might pick up gentlemen
sometimes I might pick up an [ __ ]
excuse my language but I get paid pretty
well I bet I could actually say that now
the [ __ ] they try to come with the
twenty and forty type of thing but my
journey at a time when I catch a date
even if it's at the end of the night
it'll be like a hundred or more I
believe that that's the ones I go for
like guys like guys is better why I love
me some light man
how you gon like I love white men cuz
they are sweethearts black men honor
they in the ass holes some of them not
but my journey of are where do you guys
go to hotel well the white guys always
take mutual wholesales it'd be an
expensive smoothie Fox Mustang or
American n or something like that now
the black guys they they more of a car
action I try to get them out the way
fast
so I'm get away from them as fast as
possible your car yeah but my white male
friends I kind of like them more I think
in a long run I think I might end up
marrying away man I'm not sure but I
think that's what might have yeah pretty
much say how do you pick them up
I just walk I could be walking to the
store just walking down the street
randomly walking and Bill's stopping
offering me sure they will in this
neighborhood yeah pretty much
are you using any drugs yes a slow caddy
which is which is cocaine crack cocaine
I'm starting to get kind of tired of it
which is a good thing for me I really
don't need a program because cocaine is
crack as a mind thing and really
truthfully all drugs are minding if you
let it take over you it will if you're
strong enough to fight it anymore me on
the other hand I use cocaine it's like a
numbing medicine it numbs me from my
kids being gone my other three being at
home my mom I don't go around my kids I
because I don't want them to see their
mother like that
so you're running around the street
while your mom's taking care of your
kids yes and I respect her for that I
love her for that because she took on my
responsibility that I used to once upon
a time at which I'm trying to get back
to that because I miss being a mommy
even though I know I'm a mom I miss
being a mommy to my kids my son he begs
me to come home but I can't go around
them like that I want to be completely
clean and sober when I go around my
babies so if I'm high I won't go home
when I come down and I'm sober is when I
go home other than that I don't go
losing your grandmother was hard for you
I'm very because she died on my oldest
daughter's birthday which I was actually
on my way to see her and they told me
that she was expired
and I didn't know
and
if it really [ __ ] me up that she
passed away because that was really the
only person I had besides my kids that's
really the only person I had that had my
back 100% no matter what I did my granny
saved me from everyday so this is
actually my first year going through
this without my granny who I hate most
enough but I know she looking down on me
what would your grandmother say to you
right now she would whoop my ass right
now I swear to you not now while I'm
sitting here she would be proud of me
but when I go outside the door she would
kick me in my ass honestly because my
granny wanted me to quit smoking and I
made a promise to her that I was gonna
get it together
and now that it's 2020 I'm gonna keep my
promise
turn because she really did care about
me she really loved me she just wanted
the best for me and just so she knows I
do love you granny I'll lay you dearly
whoo all right Tee tee thank you for
Kiowa
you